un million d'autos test de dépistage du
coc u19 c'est la commande passée par le
groupe carrefour dans le but de les
commercialiser en ce premier week-end de
printemps
jérôme salomon le directeur de la santé
avait d'ailleurs vanté la simplicité
d'utilisation de ces tests mais aussi la
facilité d'organisation les à ce
dispositif
ça va être assez facile d'accès puisque
le principe de l'auto thèse c'est
justement qu'on puisse la voir en
famille peut-être en supermarché ou en
officine si c'est le plus facile ça va
être très facile à organiser pour autant
la commande du groupe carrefour risque
d'être stockés dans l'arrière boutique
un bon moment car si la haute autorité
de santé a donné son aval à
l'utilisation de ces auto test le 16
mars dernier la loi elle interdit leurs
ventes en dehors des officines
autrement dit si une grande surface
décide de les commercialiser
elle sera donc dans l'illégalité c'est
en tout cas le contenu de l'article l42
11-1 du code de la santé sont réservés
aux formations sauf les dérogations
prévues aux articles du présent code
la vente au détail et tout dispensation
de dispositifs médicaux de diagnostic in
vitro destinés à être utilisés par le
public à l'exception des tests destinés
au diagnostic de la grossesse ainsi que
des tests d'ovulation
il faudrait donc un arrêté pour que les
grandes surfaces puisse vendre ces
dispositifs
autre bémol ces autos tests ne seront
pas pour autant disponible dans toutes
vos pharmacie tout de suite alors qu'ils
devaient l'être dès cette semaine leur
commercialisation à grande échelle
devrait être effective dans un deuxième
temps la première étape étant consacré à
une expérimentation pour évaluer la
qualité des prélèvements obtenu